foreign
over the last 11 years the number of
people in Japan has been shrinking
instead of growing 2022 saw the biggest
decline on record and according to some
estimates Japan's population could be
cut in half by the end of the century
Elizabeth Palmer looks at one Region's
effort to grow and the family that is
trying to reverse that Trend one child
at a time
the shoes give it away this isn't your
average Japanese home
11 people live here along with their dog
all origami into a tiny house in Nagoya
welcome to the uata family
mother of The Brood Aries shows me
around her kitchen and nope there's no
dishwasher she tells me it is a huge
amount of work but she and her husband
love a big family
some people can't or won't have kids she
says but I can and this country needs
children so I kept having more nine of
them in all
see you later is one of Japan's largest
families have become reality TV stars
they're overflowing home
and Lively family outings are
fascinating to our country that has one
of the lowest birth rates in the world
you can see it in rural areas where
thousands of houses have simply been
abandoned and this used to be a store
like the one Utah Yamashita is showing
me in kamakawa about 350 miles west of
Tokyo it's huge back at the office he's
got dozens more at fire sale prices
yamashita's job is enticing new
residents to kamikawa its selling points
are plenty of space and natural beauty
and government incentives
[Music]
these last six or seven years he told me
we are concentrating on attracting new
residents of child bearing age
one package is pitched at women who
often need extra support
single moms Yoko Morata moved here with
her two boys in 2021
the town found me a job she said a place
to live and child care and while I was
getting a driver's license the town
staff even babysat for me
people have become kamikawa's most
precious resource and it's competing
with communities across Japan to offset
its graying population with young blood
but rural areas no matter how lovely or
generous face another problem besides
overall declining population
[Music]
[Applause]
May is the uata's third eldest child and
she stars on her own YouTube channel she
loves singing about country roads but
actually live on one not a chance like
most Japanese she is a city creature no
matter how crowded
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
kamakawa
That's What I Call doing your part all
right